Richard Sol Lenny Kaye and I really were
the founders of the Patti Smith group
and put together most of the material on
horses and Richard was classically
trained he was younger than we were
quite beautiful and I thought there was
a picture of him but very very beautiful
and so and we was very attached to him
and he really he was aptly named being
Richard Sol and he put that element
within our music and it is his birthday
he died at 37 of a pulmonary heart
disease he had a faulty heart valve and
so he was quite young and but we salute
him happy birthday Richard
[Applause]
[Music]
I was away
[Music]
I'm the ocean
sort of explain
[Applause]
and I was free
nobody
it was beautiful
it was beautiful
I was a pawn
could make them
Clinton girl
nowhere
no future at all
[Music]
yet I was free
Nina
no butter
in one
beautiful
it was beautiful
and if there's one thing
could I do for you
[Music]
in heaven
I was a vision
in another eye
and I saw nothing
future at ah
[Music]
here I was free
a minute
nobody
[Music]
it was beautiful
and if there's one thing
[Music]
could do for you
you be
[Music]
in heaven
[Music]
and if there's one thing
[Music]
for you
[Music]
ah
[Music]
thank you thank you